[Music]
hey you guys here we are back once again
yep talking about another movie i think
you're you're going into the next
person's video
all right
get back in there yeah we're here move
that well hold on is that one okay and
that one's moving you off the camera
moved
no no no it's spock's in the right spot
yeah he didn't move did he no you're not
walking around on me
okay
spock's like moving around yeah
everybody's he's trying to get out he's
trying to get into the next video zach
is pissed because he did he missed the
[ __ ] haunting uh uh stream last night
that said that's his favorite episode
you missed time sorry we missed it
you got to see it recorded
yeah but we're having fun with the
haunting episodes yeah we are having
glad we brought that back
yeah those are super super fun yeah
those are super fun [ __ ] i'd even do
another one i don't give a [ __ ] i'd do
two days
somebody said somebody said and this was
actually a good idea they said oh you
should do like a wednesday night show
like a main show about like just
generally like haunted
pubs and bars yeah and i said oh that is
a good idea so i actually put it in the
patreon poll like that's going up on
friday so we'll see if it wins i don't
know if it will or not um the show that
we're doing tomorrow
is actually uh
john hague
haig hi
the acid bath murderer oh okay 1940s
yeah yeah yeah oh 40s
yeah he's got the barrels
yeah it was free he's a british guy yeah
oh okay there was a couple of them that
were like that then yes there's more
this is that scary there's more than one
acid bath burner yeah there's a couple
of those
yeah [ __ ] are weird well i
don't really understand the acid but i
guess they're just not good with they
don't have field skills well they were
trying to they thought that it would
just dissolve the body completely and
then there wouldn't be well yeah but
that's they thought that that's why
right well like i said we'll save it for
tomorrow because that's like tomorrow
okay yeah so we could talk about that
tomorrow yeah um you know okay so the
movie we're talking about today um we i
think we brought this up yesterday but
louie
sent us this beautiful
steel book
of brian de palma's yeah the
untouchables from 1987.
it's a steelbook 4k cover i love that
cover that's awesome we can't play it
yeah
xbox one doesn't seem to play 4k i don't
know if there's i don't know if there's
a um
special app that i can download there
might be but i don't know you might have
to you might have to have a 4k tv that's
what i'm thinking i think i don't think
i have a 4k tv i could i could try to
download something like that later i'll
see it but anyway we were still able to
watch it because
hbo
hbo plus yeah it was not hbo max yeah so
we watched that last night and i
actually had it and now had you ever
seen it
oh yeah i think i've seen this twice
already but it was like back in 87 yeah
i think i saw it back in the 80s or the
early 90s i liked it back then
yeah i did too as a kid your taste isn't
that good you know i mean well you know
when something's good but you don't
realize why it's good
and watching this [ __ ] again for the
second time as an adult that has a lot
better taste in things and pays
attention more closely
brian de palma is off a [ __ ] chain in
this he's off the [ __ ] chain i mean
this is visually just a gorgeous movie i
mean you could probably say that about
every brian de palma movie because
that's kind of his thing
but shot composition and everything
is [ __ ] magnificent
and the storytelling is great
and
it transports you back into the 30s i
mean you believe you're there
there were shows long shots of [ __ ]
long streets and you see those old
[ __ ] cars going all the way down and
i don't know how and they were moving
i mean they did shoot it in chicago so
it's not like because i was watching it
and because um
brian de palma's stuff is usually like
so stylized
for a second i was like is this whole
thing like one big set because it almost
looked like it was a big set
but when i looked it up they said no
they actually did film it like on
location like some of the stuff wasn't
chicago like some of the like other uh
you know locations they had to like fill
in other places but most of the [ __ ]
around the streets and everything like
that was absolutely filmed in chicago so
i thought that was like kind of cool
actually yeah and um
all the guns
were period accurate with the exception
of one shot
you know i'm a stickler on things and i
can go back and check the dates
but remember there's a famous scene
where um
elliot ness is trying to save a baby
carriage and goes through a gunfight at
the same time
at the very end
uh the bookie that they're trying to
capture is being held hostage by one of
the gangsters
and if you look at the side when that
gangster is pointing that gun at his
head
it appears to be
at first glance a 1911 45 auto but you
see it has an external extractor which
means it's a star
it's a star model b
or a um
a spanish uh pistol kind of like a uh
what was the name of that thing
that they had
not a star i forgot what it was i had to
i'd have to [ __ ] i gotta jog with
memory again but that was not a an
american pistol
now i i don't know if those existed in
the in the early 30s i know they did in
the late 30s but i don't know if they
exist in the early 30s but close we'll
see i got i got to double check on that
[ __ ]
but that wasn't a 1911. that was a star
or what was that damn [ __ ]
it was a it was a copy of a cult 1911
that the that the uh
yama or some people called llamas that's
what it was either
the
correct pronunciation is a yama
uh it was either a yama or a star which
were both good
but that wasn't american
i'm not sure why he would have that okay
but anyway besides that
this movie is [ __ ]
perfect several people pointed out what
i was gonna say when you were talking
about that last scene with the baby
carriage like in union station
everything like that and several people
have already pointed out before i had a
chance to say anything uh is that scene
is actually an homage to the 1920s film
battleship potemkin okay which also had
like the woman and the baby and all that
kind of stuff so it is actually now
let's uh
let's clear out the elephant in the room
which is
that this movie
uh students if you ever have to write
like a report about al capone and elliot
ness and stuff like that don't watch
this movie and write a report about it
because pretty much you're nothing this
movie isn't here
it's action movies
you're gonna get in big trouble if you
actually kind of like other than some of
the characters being the same like some
of this stuff is accurate but most of it
is absolutely not like most of it like
absolutely did not happen
so i'm just saying that right now but
i mean it's it's a good movie besides
that i mean and it's written by uh david
mamet obviously he did probably you know
him from glengarry glen ross but he's
written like [ __ ] tons of other stuff
too so this has like a lot of that great
like real pithy like dialogue and i had
forgotten because i hadn't seen this
movie in such a long time i had
forgotten how many iconic
uh lines were in this movie like all
this stuff about you know bringing a
knife to a gunfight and stuff about um
you know i want him dead i want his
family dead i want his house burned to
the ground like that i was like oh yeah
i forgot that was totally from this
movie
and uh you know you send one of his
hospital or he sends one of yours to the
hospital you someone this is a morgue
all that kind of stuff so all those like
really really famous lines are from this
movie which i had actually like
forgotten it's because i hadn't seen it
for such a long time my favorite line in
this i think
is
the part at the end where he throws that
dude off the building
and then like the dude crashes through
the car and then like he comes in and
they're like hey where's needy that was
the guy um
you know frank nitty or whatever his
name is um and he's like he's in the car
just kind of like that was pretty great
now like i said that is also totally
inaccurate that dude was not murdered by
elliot ness actually he wasn't murdered
at all he actually committed suicide um
12 years like after al capone went to
prison and he actually like ran the
chicago outfit i think for like a little
while so like i said very very
inaccurate but as long as you're going
not going into it hoping that it's going
to be like a historically accurate thing
because if you're really like want to be
nitpicky about it
elliott ness didn't really have hardly
anything to do with al like bringing
down al capone
you know what i mean yeah that was
almost all that accountant guy which the
accountant guy in this movie
is loosely based on a real guy but
that's not like the same guy like he has
a different name and everything but that
guy spent like years and years and years
like him and his team like combing
through all of the financial records you
know to get him and everything like that
so it wasn't really um
elliottness and the untouchables and all
that stuff's too much that was like all
uh all up in there they're asking me
what my drink is that's damn diet root
beer
publix public or or
maybe they were asking what mine is that
was iced tea okay or maybe they're
talking about you i'm not really sure
yeah mine is uh vodka and berry and
berry yeah tropical very tropical
i went and checked i was correct
many of the guns in the film including
what i talked about were star model bees
and they used them they were supposed
they used them in the action sequences
because the star model b was nine
millimeter and they worked better with
blanks than the 45s
so that's why the star model b didn't
come out until 1972 or in the 70s maybe
around that time so i was right but it's
okay it's okay close
and then in some of the in some of the
other shots establishing shots they use
1911s but in this movie when they're
doing shootouts they're star model b's
usually
according to the internet database
zach says who should have gotten the
supporting actor award for this movie
more sean connery or robert de niro now
uh spoiler alert sean connery did get
the best supporting actor oscar uh this
year for this movie even though he did
get criticized a lot for they're like
dude uh he's supposed to be like an
irish-american but he very clearly has a
very thick scottish accent which you
know is a completely different uh accent
than americans did no than an american
is it yeah well i'm just kind of said
like it didn't bother me though um
honestly i don't know i i really liked
sean connery in this like i thought he
uh he gave like the movie a lot of heart
in the body you know what though you're
right in the 30s the scholars have been
lumped in with the damn irish anyway
mostly there's like what's that they
would have known any difference really
yeah that's why it didn't bother me that
much like i'm just saying like even at
the time like in 1987 everybody was like
what the [ __ ]
you know what i mean scott's welsh irish
they would have called you all mixed
back then they wouldn't have
differentiated
i do like de niro in this though yeah um
i know i have seen some like uh reviews
that said he was kind of like a little
over the top where he was like a cartoon
character but
i mean al capone was kind of like that
you know what i mean
and honestly like he wasn't really i
mean he wasn't really in it that much to
be honest like for being like al capone
he's kind of like but i kind of like
that they did that they almost kind of
like kept him on the fringes of the
action like all the time like he was
almost like overseeing it because he's
protected
yeah that too
fantastic hotel and stuff yeah which i
don't i don't remember i mean i i
remember a lot reading a lot about him
i don't know if he lived in that much
opulence i think he tried to keep that
stuff down a little bit trying to i
think he did live in that hotel though
where he shot that yeah but i don't i
remember correctly he he wasn't that
opulent he was trying to
pass himself off as a guy that didn't
make that much money but well i don't
know though it's hard to say i know he
ate pizza all the time there was a pizza
place he constantly went to
yeah yeah and the the one scene though
do you know the one scene like after uh
elliot ness and the untouchables like
they like raid the warehouse like
looking for the booze right
and the one guy i guess that was
responsible for that and then he has
like this big dinner party and you know
al capone's being all like magnanimous
and stuff and then he picks up a bat and
like just like beats the [ __ ] out of
that guy like
um well no something like that something
like that did happen but i think it was
actually two guys it didn't have
anything to do with the raid i don't
think but um he was known for doing that
long even before he was real famous and
rich yeah beating a dude out with a
baseball bat but that happened out in
the middle street and then you had
something with his sister
if i remember correctly like somebody
had insulted his sister and he beat the
[ __ ] out of a baseball bat i'm not real
sure but the thing about how he got one
of the things that they kind of go into
a lot into this in this movie that is
like i said a little bit inaccurate is
that al capone generally
um
tried to keep violence against uh
innocent people and against cops and
stuff like that like
to an absolute minimum just because he
thought that it would bring too much
heat down on them it was bad for
business all this other kind of stuff
it's like yeah he would absolutely like
[ __ ] up another gangster that's you know
that's fine but we're in the game like
yeah the scene where like in this one
that's uh the scene that gets elliot
ness like involved in the whole thing um
where
the guy comes and like blows up that
that bar or whatever and like that
little girl gets blown up yeah that
didn't happen no i think someone got
killed in [ __ ] drive-bys though i
think some i think a kid got kicked but
didn't that right i think that was right
i think that brought in a lot of the nfa
and the gun control acts
is because some some kids got caught in
a crossfire of a drive-by
with the in the back seat there were two
guys shooting thompson submachine guns
yeah i mean that might have happened i'm
just saying this this stuff from the
movie that was like not but what
actually
what actually brought down like the you
know the the federal thing was actually
the same valentine's day massacre that's
kind of what brought a lot of attention
to it where they just lined all those
dudes up against the walls yeah that was
like the straw that broke the camel's
back right a bunch of other stuff that
had been happening yeah but i'm just
saying that the little girl like getting
blown up that didn't really happen and
the thing about it too was that like i
said it's just as long as you kind of
like think of it as like a historical
like fiction that has some real people
in it but then like kind of goes off on
fanciful directions just to make like a
good story then i think it's actually
like a really great one
like i said just don't expect it to be
historically accurate because no they're
just trying to make a movie that's kind
of like the godfather yeah you know
where the godfather was
just kind of vaguely based on kind of
the concept of an italian crime family
it's the same thing they just threw in
some
historical characters in there to try to
give it more credibility and like you're
going on a damn adventure
you know and you got sean connery
basically being the damn obi-wan kenobi
teaching the the young new cops how to
be they're not really cops so they're
just agents
you know it's getting he's a treasury
agent yeah elliot nasa is yeah so
yeah so that's kind of like he becomes k
i think in the movie
the catalyst for
elliot ness
you know wanting to get al capone is the
little girl getting blown up in the
bombing yeah right
um which al capone supposedly uh was
behind
so in the movie they make it that and
they kind of make a big deal about this
that eliot ness is like married and has
a kid now he was married um i don't
think he had a kid
i think he had a kid but later you know
what i mean like he didn't have a kid at
this point because i think he'd only
been married for like uh for not very
long of a time but they wanted to like
kind of have give him like a personal
reason because i think one of the things
that they were going for when brian de
palma and david mamet and then were like
working on this movie
was i mean obviously they had made like
the tv series with robert stack
the untouchables and you know they made
him like a very stoic tough guy
character in that one and they said well
we wanted him to be more like a human
like a vulnerable family man type of guy
because they thought that would be more
interesting now
like i said the you know kevin costner's
character like playing elliot ness in
this he is kind of like elliot ness was
they absolutely did say that elliot ness
was uh a boy scout
and that they said that the [ __ ] about
like him like not drinking and stuff
like that that was [ __ ] like he was
actually a big drinker but yeah he
actually he actually was one of the guys
that like wouldn't take bribes yeah you
know what i mean so he was like actually
like pretty honorable and like above the
level
there's kind of a
untold moral to this whole story
these federal agencies
like the irs and again the treasury
departments and nfa and
fbi they all came from this
kind of era
and after some of it after world war ii
and it was always
a federal agency
trying to
do something because a state wouldn't do
it a state government wouldn't or
couldn't do it and in this case it was
prohibition
the federal government's trying to
enforce prohibition on states that don't
really want it
i kind of felt like most states didn't
want it like nobody wanted it it was
like super unpopular so then the feds
come in and go you damn state
governments are corrupt as hell you're
in bed with all these gangsters so we're
gonna
step over you and enforce all this on
you that
totally undemocratic
because prohibition itself was federal
full of [ __ ] [ __ ] okay it was
basically a small minority of people
enforced a moral opinion on the whole
[ __ ] country
all right so it was kind of like an
uh same old thing imperial power and
they said well we're clean and you all
are dirty you're going to listen to us
that [ __ ] went over like a fart in a
space suit prohibition didn't work none
of that [ __ ] works
and then eventually
the corruption eventually makes its way
to the [ __ ] imperial level and then
the federal government is enforcing
corrupt and evil rules on the [ __ ] on
states
which is it's a universal it happened in
rome it's it's going it it happens in in
china
it's it's just you do not want to
centralize power
it always ends up being bad which rule
runs the cycle of this [ __ ] you gotta
then you gotta [ __ ] take apart an
empire
that's
abusing its people and oppressing them
it's better to let locals handle their
own [ __ ] business let them decide
that [ __ ]
the thing about this though i mean it
does kind of go they do like exaggerate
the corruption i'm not saying that
chicago wasn't corrupt at this time
because it absolutely was and a lot of
higher ups were on the take
um you know because like i said it
wasn't
well it wasn't so much that al capone uh
you know was violent toward because in
this movie they shouldn't like actually
killing like something like he killed
the accountant and he killed like us
which didn't happen in real life
but
normally like he wouldn't do that kind
of thing because obviously like bribes
worked better
but some of the stuff they show in this
movie like the police what was he like
the police commissioner or the police
chief like being on the take that
actually wasn't true um so they did
actually like exaggerate a lot of the
corruption that was going on it was
corrupt but not as corrupt as they
showed in the movie yeah although the
thing about where you were i kind of
laughed because the scene at the end
where al capone is actually like in the
courtroom
and he's like he's you know they got him
on tax evasion i think everybody like
pretty much knows that because that was
all they could get him on because he was
so well protected in other ways they had
to like find the [ __ ] in the armor
so that he's in the courtroom at the end
and he's all like man i got this you
know what i mean because he already
knows that he's paid off all the jurors
right and then the judge comes out and
says hey i'm going to switch the juries
and i'm sitting there going wait a
minute you can't do that like not at the
end of the trial now so i looked it up
this did happen but not at the end of
the trial what ended up happening was
that the judge knew ahead of time that
the jurors had been paid off so at the
beginning of the trial he said oh guess
what i'm bringing in this other jury
from over here because he knew that
that's what was going on because i was
like i'm pretty sure that once the
trial's over you can't just like switch
juries out because it's like the jury
that came in or just like what the
[ __ ] going on we didn't hear any
evidence or anything so but yeah but it
did happen like the jury switcheroo but
it was just like at the beginning of the
trial and not the end
so i wanted to like get into that a
little bit too but you know that's what
i'm saying so
uh
yeah honestly this is
i had a really good time with this movie
this movie even though like i said it's
not historically accurate but it is like
really really entertaining yeah it's
really stylish
it's like really really cool to look at
a lot of the um scenes like um
zach was bringing up that scene with uh
with sean connery and kevin costner in
the church like what was kind of like
and we mentioned this a little bit when
we were talking about blowout the other
day like with that uh that shot of like
john travolta like in the foreground and
then like all the stuff going on in the
background they had kind of he had kind
of a scene like that he didn't do any
split screen in this though
uh but he had a scene kind of like that
where someone was in the foreground in
the background it was like a really
really beautiful shot and like i said
all of the
i think split from the screen would have
taken you out of this movie
yeah i think he made the wise decision
to
not have that in this one it didn't well
it didn't really call for it because i
know that brian de palma kind of uses
split screen a lot but i think that most
of the time that he uses it like he used
it in uh blowout and sister
terry well it's i think he uses it when
he wants like two things going on at
once it's like oh here's somebody coming
up the stairs and here's somebody like
trying to clean up a body or something
like that so it's like it's like a
tension building device the way i
interpreted it is that the movie was
supposed to have a 1930s motif
it's not try it's trying to put you into
a period
so it's trying to be very artistic the
shock composition
is
kind of symmetric in a way almost kind
of like trying to trying to make
everything feel art deco but modern
because art deco was modern when it came
out yeah you know i still love i still
love uh art deco and art though i love
those looks right so
doing a split screen no that's 70s that
would take you out of it
so
they're trying to give you a very i
don't i don't want to say formal and
austere but still
action-packed
it's trying to feel
crisp and clean like art deco and
i want to say weird like conservatively
shot you know nothing high-tech nothing
but it is it's hiding in the fact that
it's itech
it's yeah
i know what you're saying he's trying to
look very sophisticated i get what
you're saying it works it works
kind of like the way a monument is
supposed to look monumental you know the
way the way art deco is and i think he
[ __ ] achieved it hell yeah
the only thing that took me out was that
star bottle b but i'm an expert
i looked at that with that's not a 19.
yeah most people wouldn't mostly
wouldn't notice i didn't notice
99 of people yeah the technical reason
is that the star model b's worked better
with blake's
you're like neil degrasse tyson and
whenever he's like a historical movie
and he's just like that's not what the
stars looked like like on that
particular day yeah right
he's like yeah it's like nobody would
notice but like point zero but in the
70s
you know what i mean but uh
you know what i had forgotten
how
gory this movie is
yeah yeah i mean particularly this i
mean particularly the scene it's a
mainstream movie particularly the scene
where the accountant and the and the
snitch yeah get killed in the elevator
by billy drake that was billy drago
wasn't it yeah um playing that guy and
they kill the guy and then like write
touchable like on the wall and the blood
and it just looks like a [ __ ] slasher
movie and i was just like damn i forgot
how [ __ ] gorgeous well i think it's
the right decision the idea the idea was
is that they were glorifying [ __ ]
violence this is [ __ ] murder these
hits you know you're murdering people
and people are go people are kind of
begging before they get shot no no no no
no boom you know yeah so well they're
showing it more like it really is yeah
right yeah you know because guys gonna
go into denial no don't kill me don't
you know but there's no time you're
going to get killed that's what they
were doing this is warfare
you know it's gay one thing i did like
about this movie is that it doesn't
i want to say it doesn't i know this
might be a weird thing to say but it
doesn't really glamorize
the gangster lifestyle because a lot of
gangster movies do and i'm not saying
that they shouldn't because that's you
know if you want to make your movie like
that that's fine but this doesn't really
like glamorize it it shows al capone and
he's glamorous and everything like that
but it kind of shows how you know the
media and everything like that are very
like you know like sycophantic like
about him and it's just kind of like and
he's just kind of like
i mean in the movie he's like just this
murderous
dick but it's like everybody loves him
because he's just like funny and all
this other kind of [ __ ] so they let you
know he's a slime ball yeah yeah um and
then now i will say that i think it like
over
it like maybe over makes
like overtly hero
heroic out of the character of like
eliot ness
uh who like i said was just a flawed
human being so it almost kind of like
made him like saintly
but
i don't know i said maybe that was like
a good decision because i did like you
know he was like really saintly and he
was didn't really want to kill anybody
and he didn't want to do anything but
then at the end like when that one guy
billy drago's character was like
you know making fun of his of the guy
that he killed like his friend that he
killed and he's just like yeah i'm
throwing your [ __ ] ass up yeah no the
the palma de palma did the right thing
with it he's trying to tell an epic tale
of good versus evil he doesn't want any
gray in it
and it was portrayed it is very it is
very very black and white right and
that's and that's
that's a strong
suit in telling the stories because even
though elliot ness pushed that dude off
the [ __ ]
building he deserved it i mean that's
what the movie says
yeah he broke the law but that was the
right thing to do that [ __ ] had to go
he's in the car yeah i laughed i laughed
outside yeah he falls in the car where's
he's in the car he's in the car
that was my favorite line of them
depalma's trying to say that that the
legal system has limits especially in a
place like chicago in that situation it
was corrupt so he would have got off so
you had to go outside the law to get
that one that particular guy
yeah that particular guy was a was was a
a high-level torpedo which is an
assassin well and they knew that he had
killed killed the accountant guy and
they knew that he had killed the the
snitch guy that they were going to get
to like testify right and he was so in
with the mayor and and had bribed so
many people and was so well connected
he'd walk
if you brought him into court yeah so
it's just like he had to go
gotta push him in that particular in
that particular with that particular
offender you had to go outside a lot to
get him
i mean i feel like in the in the context
of the movie i feel like they were
almost leaning toward elliot ness was
not gonna kill that dude he probably
wouldn't have killed that dude if that
dude hadn't started like taunting him
yeah he said i killed your buddy about
how like he died like a pig or something
like that i'm just kind of like dude
you're gonna you're gonna [ __ ] burn
for it and then he said did you sound
like that yeah
he says you're gonna go basically says
you're gonna go to prison before he goes
nope i'll walk
and he probably wouldn't yeah he would
have he probably so that's that's what
tipped him over yeah because i'll walk
because and like i said i don't think
anybody would blame the guy for doing
that like i said that didn't happen in
real life well you're in a moroccan
conundrum yeah this this is
what they're what he was what de palma's
trying to show you is that there are
some criminals
that are so well connected and so
embedded into the system
that they're above the law
so what do you do to to to bring justice
you can't take him to the courts
because they won't get be justice
so in that particular case you had to do
it yourself the old-fashioned way
i mean i'm not gonna that's what they
were doing that's i would have done the
same thing that's what they were doing i
mean you're gonna be a douche up here in
my face like that yeah i'm gonna push
your ass right after that he was so
highly and not feel bad about it either
such a high level gangster that you had
to get him on the gangster side not on
the i'm not on the lo that was a great
scene by the way i really did like that
right
they were talking about what it's my
understanding that a lot of times what
happened and this
places like new orleans and stuff still
goes down and probably detroit too
is that if the cops want some dudes gone
they can't get him so
they leverage another criminal to get
him that's that's one way that they
could do it make a deal with another
criminal to take that guy out
that seems like a good i mean cia and
fbi i mean like i said that kind of
seems like a win-win situation yeah
they're like we know you did this but we
got a problem this guy's [ __ ]
dangerous if you [ __ ] take care of
that we're just gonna like look at this
year while that happens yeah we know hey
he's gonna be at this spot right and we
know you got motive i know we know what
he did to you last year that type of
[ __ ] and then they just get that guy to
do it like i said that seems like a good
way to go about things to be honest i
mean if it gets to that city tell you
right where he is and everything we know
right where he is
but i don't think that none of that's
official
that's well obviously yeah you'd have to
keep that on the down line that's
something that somebody on the beat that
knows those streets might
some detective that knows a bunch of
[ __ ] and he's got dirt on somebody and
he's might be slightly dirty they'll
take care of that [ __ ] too
but de palma did not want a story of
gray
in this one he wants yeah this is not a
morally gray no yeah i mean it
absolutely does not glamorize al capone
or any of the gangsters they're all
[ __ ]
and murderers and the untouchables are
all
honorable
men there are no
i mean they're flawed like humans but
they don't have there's no like moral
ambiguity or moral grayness or anything
like that it's very very much good
versus evil
um which like i said it's not
like real life but
it's a movie
it's just a good story like talking
about good and evil
de palma's basically kind of doing
what
milius would have done with a story like
this he would have made it an epic tale
of good versus evil with the with
like just
you know monumental [ __ ] fire fights
that [ __ ] impossible [ __ ] happens but
it worked out good you know like the
baby carriage
that was such a great scene i love that
like with a with uh andy garcia like at
the end like laying down they're like
holding up the baby carriage with his
leg and like shooting that [ __ ]
and what they are is they're kind of
like a mythology they're they're moral
tales
but they are
it's great moving so you know
on par with you know like moral tales
that you find in [ __ ] the first conan
movie which is amelia's movie
you know that's what he's doing
it's good
yeah i like when just giuseppe comes up
when he's using the name stone
you know what i mean george stone george
stone and
uh
uh
[ __ ] what's his name what's what's
that character's name that uh sean
connor was playing john connery's going
oh that what was your name before jimmy
malone yeah yeah yeah
yeah maloney's pressing him what was
your name before you changed it and yeah
this island or whatever and he just
pressed him and pressed him trying to
get him to blow to see what he would do
and he goes oh i like him he's because
he
wanted somebody that would you know
believe more in the honor system you
know and uh uh you know how to make an
honor based person more than say like a
legal based person because he pulled a
gun on another cop that threatened to
kill him right there over that because
this guy has honor i can trust him
and he just pulled him out of the
academy pulled him right out of the
county's brand new kid he was hot-headed
and he had honor and he goes this is the
guy we want
you know i said i like how he handled
that
and [ __ ] then dude because you got
the job didn't realize that the whole
thing was a test and they bonded over
that
kind of [ __ ] drill sergeants do
i really did like like the but you know
like like i said in real life the
untouchables was like a whole bunch of
dudes it wasn't just like four guys but
um but i really did like the interaction
between like all four of the actors
someone was talking about kevin costner
earlier i've never been i have to say
i've never been a huge fan of kevin
costner
um
he's good in this but
he's always blessed he's very bland
he's always been i think like i was
reading something earlier that said is
he like the whitest actor of all time
probably he can't even yell with any
basis
he's like dude did you go through
puberty
you know what put some bass in your
voice
he's just so he just always asks
hey i'm sure he's like a nice person
yeah i'm just like he never like he
never strikes me as anybody that gets
like super excited about anything or
like is like really like emotionally he
doesn't have much emotional range to his
characters um and you know admittedly i
haven't seen like a [ __ ] ton of movies
that he's been in but he's never like
terrible but he's always kind of like
just kind of like bland he's good he's
adequate but i think that it maybe it
works in this one because elliot ness
like i said is supposed to be in the
context of those
he's supposed to be like this
you know very very upright yeah boy
scout type of character they cast him
correctly now he wasn't the first choice
though um the least bland role he ever
played was the [ __ ] aquaman in water
world
the guy who could breathe
i don't kind of want to see that again
like i remember seeing the first time
like
this is terrible he's got two
great bad movies water world
it's like mad max on the ocean and then
the other one was [ __ ] uh the postman
which is another mad max kind of rip-off
based on a book
um
written by a [ __ ] dude here's a
[ __ ] dish but [ __ ] it's like that
i listen that dude he was on he was a
guest on [ __ ] um
uh one of the science programs i was on
anyway uh it was [ __ ] weird but he
wrote that
the postman and the postman was kind of
like
kind of like mad max but not really
but costner did both of those roles
pretty well yeah because that's kind of
who those characters are supposed to be
when it
when it came to grit and flavor his best
one would have been water world because
the dude he was playing was almost kind
of a bad guy almost kind of a bad guy
but he redeems himself later on he could
breathe underwater and he was a mutant
it was pretty neat
mango said he was great in field of
dreams yeah he that was probably his
best movie i think a lot of people liked
him in bull durham as well but although
it's been a long time since i've seen
that zach says i've seen dances with
wolves so at least i know costner has a
nice ass
[Laughter]
that wasn't a bad movie uh that was
actually a pretty good that was a bad
movie it's pretty good but once again
bland
bland
mango also says and also no way out a
kraken spy thriller i don't think i've
ever seen that but i have seen a lot of
people
because i was reading something earlier
and a lot of people were talking about
uh
we're talking about kevin costner's who
said this performance manga said that i
said um
and they said no he's really good and no
way out and i was like well probably i
should see that then because i don't
think i've ever seen that movie unless i
just saw it in front of somebody sends
us a copy we'll put it in in line with
the with the the hard copies that we
have it goes to the top
requests man we got [ __ ] people sent us
movies we still got to do
um
godfather one two and three yeah we've
done god by the way i remember god
father two being good
well godfather two gets brought up a lot
as being like one of the best sequels of
all time yeah i remember being [ __ ]
just
like like like like mega says kraken
that was a cracking sequel zack said we
should do road to perdition oh i agree
that's probably that's a good movie too
road to partition was really good um
yeah so i was gonna say that kevin
costner was actually not the first
choice
uh the first choice and let's see how
you feel about this the first choice i
believe that de palma wanted was don
johnson
and this was 87 so this was prime
minister miami vice
era
yeah yeah he might have worked he worked
he might have worked i actually kind of
like don johnson yeah and he like
actually did some cool [ __ ] like later
on too like when he got a little bit
older one of my favorite one of don
johnson okay i got it i got the [ __ ]
blu-ray it's in public domain though but
you could buy copies of it supposedly
blu-ray [ __ ] quality
on ebay people were bootlegging them
because there's a public domain it's
called a boy and his dog
and it's a yeah that's right i forgot
yeah my favorite don johnson movie don
john's good in that is it a
post-apocalyptic world he's kind of like
a mad max kind of character but he's
just this scumbag running around with
this dog and a dog is some kind of
cybernetic
police dog that used to be around you
know back but and it's evidently really
anxious it may not be a real
dog it's probably a robot dog
and it follows him around and it's got
all these abilities and its abilities to
sniff out females women that's what he's
using it for
and he's raping and killing women
yep
yeah we reviewed that movie yeah a while
back and he didn't think anything of it
everybody else is doing it
and then he gets captured by some subter
a subterranean
cult of survivors it's just like
something out of damn
fallout if you like fallout see a boy
and his dog is from the early 80s i
believe
and it might be 70s right i can't
remember when the [ __ ] that movie came
out yeah and there's a damn subterranean
cult captures them and they they've
recreated like the 1950s
1950s southern living like on the farm
they're doing it underneath the ground
in a cave
neighborhoods and everything they're
having [ __ ] picnics and they're
they've they [ __ ] abducted him
to use him as breeding stock and then it
gets weird but it gets really weird but
it's a [ __ ] great movie real low
budget kind of well written it has a lot
of comedy in it it's like a dark comedy
and it's got action
and you're like what the [ __ ] is this
that movie would never fly today because
the hero is a [ __ ] serial rapist and
a murderer
all right but he's like a savage he
doesn't [ __ ] know he's got a
bolt-action rifle in the 70s were a
weird time yeah it's a weird time
he's like a bad guy from the mad max
universe
yeah yeah
but yeah so
yeah so like i said i think don johnson
was the first choice other actors that
they asked but couldn't do it or turned
it down mickey rourke
i don't know if that would have worked
so like i said me i love mickey rourke
but
he seems like too much of a scumbag i
don't you know just as an actor i don't
know what he's like as a real person but
he seems like too much of a scumbag to
play like somebody upright like elliot
ness they also has jeff bridges that
might have worked uh william hurt also
might have worked harrison ford and
michael douglas uh but they all turned
it down uh then they also wanted uh jack
nicholson and actually they went and i
don't think that one no
when you said harrison ford harrison
ford this would probably work with
harrison ford it probably would have
yeah i kind of or william william or
jeff bridges i think would have worked
too because you need somebody
that
has kind of like that all-american every
man like good guy type of
you know what i mean like like he's not
he's not some [ __ ] that you met
in the university per se
but he's skilled
he's kind of an all-rounder you know
what i mean
because that's really who harrison ford
was he you called him to come fix your
[ __ ] cabinets all right that's how he
got his that's how [ __ ]
that's how george lucas met him you know
he was working on cabinets but he could
do a little bit of everything and
lucas was impressed with him and put him
in american graffiti
because he was ahead of all american
all-round kind of guy
that you could trust him to maybe do
anything and maybe he might be able to
do it
that's why indiana jones worked
there's nothing not there wasn't one
thing about indiana jones that made
those tales seem plausible it was a
bunch of little things about him
he was just kind of an all-around guy
and and you bought it you bought it yeah
and maybe he could actually pull this
[ __ ] off it wasn't that he was a great
scholar or anything that wasn't part he
was smart but he could do a little bit
of everything he could he had a bullwhip
he could run he could jump he could
shoot a pistol he could [ __ ] talk to
women he could uh talk to other scholars
he could
intimidate people if he had to he's just
an all-around guy a little bit of
everything worked it worked and he was a
labrador retriever of men
they could do a little bit of everything
and i think that's kind of what you
needed for this role yeah to play elliot
ness you need somebody that it's like
it's not going to be silly if they're in
a gunfight but
then you need somebody that's like you
know smart enough to like outsmart
gangsters and like all this other kind
of stuff so and like i said you need
somebody that seems like
i don't want to go so far as to say
saintly but you need somebody that's
like really really like all-american
honorable like a little like purity like
yeah you so you need that kind of thing
about almost a chris reeves quality
chris
probably that's what i'm saying that's
why i don't think mickey rourke would
have worked and i don't think michael
douglas would have worked because they
have a little bit of scumbag dna in
there yeah like a little bit they just
give off that kind of like i'm a little
bit of a bad guy you can't really have
that like in a row every chris reeves
movie he gives off this kind of a weird
masculine purity to him that made women
wanted to have sex with him
and you always want wondered whether or
not this [ __ ] was a virgin
superman comes off as a virgin he does
absolutely yeah and and i'm sure
christopher reeve was not a virgin at
the time but it was just kind of like
but he really did
that superman comes off as a virgin
character that's why he's the best
superman yeah because he's absolutely
like i would have you told me superman
was a virgin i would absolutely agree
yes superman has never
been laid
[Laughter]
because he didn't want to hurt that
woman's feeling
because he can't be with her or blow her
vagina or blow the vagina
and even [ __ ]
even the cannon
the very last superman the [ __ ] one
about the new i even liked that one i
[ __ ] liked him i didn't like three
unfortunately it was a little stale
man poor richard pryor because he loved
superman movies and he was he was upset
with the way that one came out this is
just not good
i had to go back and look i couldn't
finish it i got to go see it again yeah
but these replacement supermen that they
have now in the [ __ ] dc universe man
that is not superman well i mean the
thing about it
that's not christopher i mean he there
there's some big shoes to fill there's
never going to be another guy like that
yeah he had that just everywhere his
look came together like exactly right
and like
and
his you know performance was so iconic
that everything's gonna get compared to
that and everybody's gonna fall short
because they're not him i saw the first
two superman movies one and two when i
was a kid in the theater when they came
out there was time in between i'd grown
a little bit the second one
that first one i felt like i saw
superman
as a kid like that's him
that was the impression i had i saw
superman
i knew it wasn't real yeah but i had
that feeling that i actually saw
superman
when you because chris reeves pulled
that role off so well
you know i mean he just like embodies
superman to me yeah like my mom and all
her sisters and [ __ ] you know all my
aunts wanting to [ __ ] screw
chris reeve they just [ __ ] loved him
he was he was a sex object for women i
couldn't see that
because he felt he was like a virgin
like a good looking for there was some
about magnetic about him
yeah i guess women wanted not exactly my
type but i can he was in the time in
those days he was a man of those times
and he was very different from from the
men i mean he was just a really nice man
he was a nice man yeah and that's and
that's pretty sexy
romance movies came out like time after
you know it was somewhere in time
somewhere somewhere in time came out and
[ __ ] women flooded to that movie yep
they [ __ ] flooded it damp panties
everywhere
it was i haven't seen it since i was a
kid i haven't either i wouldn't mind
actually watching that again i remember
liking it it was apparently always
time travel yeah he was in um
man what was that one like that murder
mystery that he was in that was good too
[ __ ] i forgot
that was also good i saw that like a
bunch i'm sure like somebody remembers
he was in a bunch of good murder mystery
that christopher would read it was the
agatha christie based murder mystery
wouldn't it
might have been god damn it with the
fennel it's like right on the tip of my
tongue somebody somebody somebody is
gonna like remember it in a second
know what i was going to say so yeah so
i don't know like some of those other
actors like i said i could totally see
jeff bridges or william hurt or somebody
like that
being elliot ness in this yeah and i'm
not [ __ ] on kevin costner i'm just
saying that kevin costner is always just
kind of like a little bit he always
comes across as like a little bit wooden
um he's good in this but
you know given his limitations
he i mean you know he was just kind of
like a little bit wooden now
obviously robert de niro was the first
choice for al capone so happily he was
able to do it but here's the funny thing
this is a story that i uh found on
wikipedia when i was like researching
this movie
they said they're like okay we want
robert de niro
but they didn't know if they could get
him because he had like a time conflict
with like some other [ __ ] that he was
working on so they said okay well we
have a backup plan if we can't get
robert de niro then we'll get bob
hoskins which also would have been good
although he's a brit but i i think he
can do like an okay american accent
because he was in who framed roger
rabbit and i think he did an american
accent in that
so um yeah so they said okay well bob
hoskins will have him as a backup now
when they said that they could have
robert de niro to do it they actually
sent brian de palma i think
sent
bob hoskins his fee like two hundred
thousand dollars which must be nice uh
and like a thank you note and then bob
hoskins calls him up and says hey are
there any other movies you don't want me
to be in like i just got 200 000 for
doing [ __ ] all just because he was like
the backup but you know what i mean uh
they also said that had neither of them
been able to do it then gene hackman
could have done it or maybe marlon
brando
so
yeah i could see that but honestly i
can't really see de niro i can't really
see anyone but de niro like playing al
capone in this like i said even though
he's not in it a great deal
um
he he really like kind of embodies like
he even he gained weight he was like
they said that he was really worried
about oh my face isn't round enough like
because he wanted to look like al capone
too so he insisted that he's like i have
to gain all this weight and all this
other kind of stuff and he like really i
think he did a good job he's calling big
al for nothing he was big he was a big
dude pretty big dude but he was also
pudgy actually he was eating good yeah i
mean yeah i wouldn't call him fat but he
definitely was pudgy that's yeah he was
pudgy like almost kind of and he had a
very pudgy brown face it's kind of kind
of like a smaller version of the dude
that played kingpin
he was yeah he wasn't that big i don't
think in terms of height but
yeah because that dude is like really
big that dude's enormous yeah vincent
for sure i'm not sure uh capone actually
reached six feet i think he was under
six feet but yeah i thought he was
shorter i think he might have been 510
but he just was a big meady guy
death trap thank you yeah death trap
that's what it was i saw that a million
times like back on cable not a bad movie
it's actually yeah i remember really
liking it yeah and it's paranormal
dude's got [ __ ] psychokinetic
abilities he's basically like a sith
that's another one we should [ __ ]
yeah i wouldn't mind having that one
i was that was another movie then these
are kind of like other unexplored movies
that i used to watch a lot on cable back
in the old days like back in the early
80s
and death wrap was one of them and what
was the one
with
chevy chase and goldie hawn
and burgess meredith
and burgess meredith had a snake named
esme
and it was a murder mystery what the
[ __ ] was the name of that [ __ ] i saw
that like a million times and it was
like right around the time that death
trap came out man i used to love that
movie there's another one from that time
i've been wanting to see again was being
there peter sellers that's a [ __ ]
that's on hbo max i keep telling you i
put it in i want i want to copy that
[ __ ] i put it in
the patreon poll like for the next is
anybody voting for it i don't well i
don't know because the the poll for next
week doesn't go up until friday yeah the
poll for this week had already done and
it's misery it's got all that secret
society uh stuff you know being there
burgers and with being there slightly
paranormal i guess
foul play thank you okay foul play
that's the name of it i saw that one a
million times i think that was kind of
one of the only movies well maybe other
than the european like the vacation and
european vacation movies that uh didn't
make me want to punch chevy chase
although fletch was good too another one
i want to see from around that time was
a peter sellers movies called the
fiendish plot of dr phu manchu oh i
remember that one and i'm not sure it
would fly today because he's dressed as
a chinese guy but
it's not christopher lee played foo
manchu yeah so in probably the worst
movie ever it's a story of a man
searching for trt
okay
trying to get his mojo back but the mit
has to force trt into every single
remember he tries to get younger
i have you know i was a kid the last
time yeah i absolutely
how to get his sexual prowess back
okay and uh yeah i forgot he was wearing
out yeah and he'd had some elixir vitae
it was something that he could make it
he'd get him
and it [ __ ] reverses [ __ ] aging a
bit kinda he just you know there's
makeup but
and then uh yeah but i have to it's been
a long time i've seen it
i just i remember watching that movie
because i was kind of like when i was a
little kid
i would see a movie with a title like
that and be like oh it's going to be
like a horror movie and then like
sometimes i would watch it i'll be like
this isn't a horror movie this is boring
dark comedy with hints with musical had
parts of musical was in it too cause he
did musical apps so probably when i was
a little kid i was just kind of like
what the [ __ ] is this i thought it was
gonna be scary yeah
no
i wouldn't mind seeing the pink panther
movies again see if those were still
funny yeah i remember seeing a bunch i
remember them being funny but it may not
be funny today
uh zach says also y'all forgot to bring
up uh any of moriconi's music for this
movie actually yeah the score in this is
great it's um
it's it's a very very yeah it's like a
very epic very hollywood they actually
played the score on the [ __ ] top 40
radio stations when this movie was out
remember that
i do not really they had a certain edit
they had that dude
the [ __ ] theme from the damn
i remember that they played that on the
[ __ ] world they really really did
yeah it's an untouchable steam like i
said i this was a massive [ __ ] movie
like i've hit well yeah it made like a
[ __ ] ton of money i think it was like
the sixth highest grossing movie that
year like i said it got nominated for a
bunch of academy awards and it got like
pretty much all
good reviews so i saw it when i was in
high school and everybody loved it
yeah everybody was talking about it well
it's a real
crowd pleaser it's a crowd-pleasing
movie like i said it's there's no moral
ambiguity it's very good versus evil
it's everybody loves gangster movies but
it doesn't have
you know even though it's based on real
historical stuff like it just kind of
does its own thing so it kind of has
character development it has gore it has
violence it has you know it's just like
a fun i know it's kind of a weird thing
to say because you know it's people
getting murdered and stuff but it's just
it's an entertaining it's just very
entertaining crowd-pleasing
movie like you know what i mean and i
feel like there was a lot of those in
the 80s like they really came out with a
bunch of movies that kind of everybody
would go see
whether you were a teenager or whether
you were like 80 years old
like everybody had to go see that [ __ ]
yeah
this was an era where a tentpole flick
didn't have to be a superhero movie or
something like fast interferes with just
explosions and cars it would it could
have a real story it could be a period
piece and this is an excellent period
piece i mean it's [ __ ] awesome it
really is it's so [ __ ] stunning
everybody would go see it
you know you're like oh yeah i feel like
every [ __ ] went to school
everybody was talking about it yeah it
was like you know on par with indiana
jones or something you know that's
that's what kind of movie it was i mean
it
everybody went to go see it and like i
said i had forgotten until we were
watching it again how many iconic
lines
came from this movie yeah
you know what i mean and it's just like
kind of because i kind of judge a lot of
things by mystery science theater like
how many references they make to like
other movies and they've made a [ __ ] ton
of references to this movie and a lot of
the references i had forgotten were from
this movie because i hadn't seen it
because i hadn't seen it it's it's
basically like uh an action
adventure version of the godfather it's
a gangster movie but more from the
police point of view
not as intrigue based as say like the
godfather more
action-adventure
mythology about
trying to get something done and failing
and then making a comeback and trying to
win and it's like that you know it's a
lot more very past it's a lot more
streamlined streamlined faster i feel
like the godfather and those are more
like these epic kind of like with all
these subplots and characters yeah and
you're saver and as you're savoring
right it's happening it's not like that
this is almost more like an
action-adventure movie yeah but it's
gangster but with gangsters and it's
just [ __ ]
looks and sounds and the edit and just
the palma is [ __ ] slamming do this
and i mean and he's taking you back into
the 30s you believe you're there all the
way down to the paint big thick [ __ ]
lead-based paint that looked like [ __ ]
that they had back then i remember
[ __ ] architecture uh because yeah
detroit was filled with that [ __ ]
and i lived in some apartments that
[ __ ] was painted with that crap
it was just kind of thick paint that was
kind of glo
the colors were muted but it kind of had
a weird gloss to it and you'd see paint
chips where they were just painting over
the same paint chips all the time just
the way everything looked
and um
the cars
uh the guns
were accurate up until a certain point
but the average person wouldn't notice
uh
the clothes all right i was watching
that [ __ ] and i was going yeah i
remember
um
before synthetic materials had
synthetic materials had taken over
because this is all giorgio armani stuff
cut and they're using real
fur
real heavy horse hide and real leathers
yeah uh real tweeds and brocades and
stuff you know stuff that was based in
wool and 100 percent
sweating their balls off what was cold
i think it looked like it was partially
cold wool
uh [ __ ] like seal skin you were looking
at [ __ ] what was that [ __ ] camel what
did they call it camel not camel hair
but it was like a beige material yeah
just call it camel but i remember what
it was made out of but they were just
all natural materials that [ __ ] [ __ ]
cost a [ __ ] ton of money now
it was just fairly expensive back then
but um the clothes the the clothing was
[ __ ] fantastic the women clothing too
real silk i just saw this bit um from
wikipedia yeah that says robert de niro
had one extra scene written first
character he contacted capone's original
tailors yeah to have identical suits and
silk underwear made for him okay yeah he
wanted to like get in the hole he wanted
to feel like he was
he wanted to feel like i want to be in
the silk boxers of or whatever yeah
yeah
people don't know even connell people
don't realize today because if you go
through old vintage clothing places like
we used to go through back like in the
80s you would find stuff from the 30s
and 40s sometimes
leather jackets that still existed i
have a 1940s
world war
ii naval officers black dress code with
the big [ __ ]
and it's from the the date on the inside
is 1942.
nothing like that could be made today
and it feels like it weighs [ __ ] six
pounds it's [ __ ] heavy as [ __ ]
um people don't realize even middle of
the road
middle rung clothing were superior to
anything you could buy today they were
just [ __ ] well everything was kind of
like made to last
yeah now i mean they make everything
like more cheaply yeah and it's gone in
a year
you know because you have to replace it
yeah quicker no you could get uh leather
boots and shoes that would last decades
you know i still have a pair of
matterhorn army boots uh that uh were
issued to me extreme cold weather when i
was in korea i still have them and the
they're still usable
and there's not almost nothing going on
the tread and these and did service with
them they're [ __ ] 30 years old now
well the stuff back in the
earth 1930s was just like that it just
lasted forever
no planned obsolescence in the clothing
[ __ ]
yeah i don't think that i don't think
that concept actually came around until
like later on no everything was built to
last
and it did
and it lasted longer than synthetic
materials well and the culture didn't
move as quickly either where it was just
kind of like a thing where nowadays it's
like oh we're wearing this and then like
next year everyone's like oh you're
still wearing that yeah you know what i
mean so it's like and some of that stuff
was [ __ ] real water resistant you
wouldn't think of it but they'd spray it
with scotch guards and oil they'd oil
things like coats and [ __ ] rain had
hit it and just slide right off of it
never go through it being pouring rain
and [ __ ] stay dry
zack says uh tom's right it's sad that
the only movies that get the green light
anymore are major superhero blockbusters
and everything else is micro budget
indies you ever hear of and it's like
actors go to the tent polls to get paid
and then go to the indies to actually
act yeah which i think is why so many
stars have jumped shipped to tv these
days yeah yeah and i mean to be honest
and i've seen like some good tentpole
movies but that's why i kind of try to
like make an effort to like find series
like well series and also like indie
particularly horror movies
because that's kind of where the action
is man that's where all the good [ __ ] is
what sucks is that there isn't enough
indie sci-fi in the in in the in the
cause because it's expensive in the
realm of say like star wars and uh star
trek nothing new original coming
i mean the last thing that i saw that i
thought was super original and it was
along that line would have been hunter
prey wouldn't there didn't i say there
was a sequel to hunter prey
you should probably look more because
there's like a lot of there's a lot of
indie sci-fi yeah i don't i don't really
go more that much into it because i'm
not super into sci-fi i'm more into
horror and there's like there's so much
like good indie horror
that
it's like i'll never live long enough to
watch it all but sci-fi
that's up there too there's a lot of
really good [ __ ] you just gotta look
look for it that's all so i don't really
want to be like because i know there's
like some people's like oh nothing good
comes out and stuff like i'm like that's
[ __ ] there's tons of good [ __ ]
everywhere it's just that you have to
look for it that's all hunter prey was
an unofficial sequel to enemy mind
those those no that's what it was we saw
a blu-ray version of enemy mine and that
[ __ ] looked fantastic yeah
because we just reviewed it yeah that's
what it was a few months ago yeah those
those are enemy mine and hunter prey are
great
yeah
yeah i think we did them both the same
week actually yeah now that that's what
it was i thought that maybe there was
some kind of sequel to hunter prey
coming but i don't think so yeah all
right so
i know we m we've mostly talked about
the yeah and uh
lasagna is done probably oh yeah sure we
got a lasagna in the oven yeah all right
so thanks everybody for dropping by
today now remember tomorrow is the main
show and we're we're doing like another
serial killer case we're talking about
the acid bath murderer which i haven't
wanted to do this for like a really long
time i read a book about this
[ __ ] like when i was a kid and i
was just like oh that's [ __ ] up but
yeah so we're gonna do a show about that
tomorrow night so hopefully you guys
will stop by and hang out with us so
thanks for
coming by today and we will see you guys
again tomorrow
bye